GOALS.
X. OUT GOLF IS THE SKI
[inaudible]
GOT IT.
WELL THANK YOU FOR COMING IN
PLEASE [inaudible]
HER.
FROM THE ALEJO.
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
AND PLEASE PROCEED OF THIS AS A
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE AND I
HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR PLEASE.
SURE -- SO
AGAIN PAUL GOES ISCHEMIC THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE THE
SERGEANT IS DISTRIBUTING A
HANDOUT FROM WHICH I'LL BE
SPEAKING.
AND THEY'LL BE FOR PARTS TO MY
PRESENTATION TODAY FIRST I
WANTED TO DISCUSS BRIEFLY OUR
OFFICES ROLE AND THE INITIATIVE
PROCESS AND THEN I'D PROVIDE
SOME BACKGROUND ON FUEL AND
VEHICLE TAX IS.
AFTER THAT I'LL DESCRIBE THE
INITIATIVE PROPOSAL --
AND THEN LAST THEY'LL DISCUSS
ITS FISCAL AFFECTS.
A SO TO START --
I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT OUR
OFFICES ROLE --
IN THE INITIATIVE PROCESS IS
QUITE DE.
PROCESS --
FOR MEMBERS FOR ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
THEY MIGHT BE FAMILIAR WITH OUR
OFFICE COMING --
TO COMMITTEE --
ASSESSING VARIOUS BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS --
WE DON'T DO THAT WITH THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS BECAUSE STATE
LAW REQUIRES US TO PREPARE AN
IMPARTIAL FISCAL ANALYSIS --
SO WE DON'T --
EVALUATE THE MERITS OF
INITIATIVE PROPOSALS AND WE
DON'T MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER ON THEM --
SO MY COMMENTS TODAY WILL BE
PURELY DESCRIBING WHAT THE
MEASURE DOES AS WELL AS
ESTIMATING ITS FISCAL A FAX --
THE OTHER THING I WE KNOW IS
THAT THE HENDO AND MY COMMENTS
TODAY OUR TENTATIVE OUR FINAL
ANALYSIS ISN'T DUE TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE --
UNTIL JULY SO WE ARE STILL IN
THE PROCESS OF PREPARING IT SO I
WOULD CHEAT THESE --
REMARKS AND HENDEL AS TENTATIVE
FOR NOW.
SO IF YOU TURN TO THE PAGE OF
THE HANDOUT LABELED BACKGROUND
HOW QUICKLY.
GO OVER SOME BACKGROUND MATERIAL
TO GET YOU ORIENTED BUT YOU
PROBABLY ALREADY FAMILIAR WITH
MUCH OF IT --
AS YOU KNOW CURRENTLY THE
LEGISLATURE CAN ONLY PASS THE
TAX WITH A TWO THIRDS VOTE.
AND THE LEGISLATURE'S --
I MEAN THE VOTERS ARE NOT
INVOLVED IN --
PASSING THESE TAX INCREASES IT'S
JUST DONE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS TO THE
GOVERNOR.
I'M TERMS THIS FUEL AND VEHICLE
TAX IS SPECIFICALLY THAT ARE
CHARGED BY THE STATE AND THE
STATE HAS EXCISE AND SALES TAXES
ON GASOLINE AND DIESEL FUEL.
IS AUTHOR IN TAXES ON VEHICLES.
THE STATE CONSTITUTION REQUIRES
THAT THE REVENUES FROM THESE
TAXES BE SPENT ON TRANSPORTATION
PURPOSES.
ON WITH ONE MAJOR EXCEPTION
WHICH IS THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
ON THOSE REVENUES ARE NOT
LIMITED TO TRANSPORTATION.
AND CURRENTLY THEY LET LET JUST
THEM -- TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES AND A PUBLIC
SAFETY PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL --
SO AS YOU'RE ALL AWARE RECENTLY
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
S. B. ONE ON APRIL TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO INCREASE.
SOME OF THE FUEL AND VEHICLE TAX
IS -- TO
FUND HIGHWAY AND ROAD
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR.
AS WELL AS TRANSIT PROGRAMS
ANOTHER TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS.
AND THERE'S A FIGURE ON PAGE --
TO WHERE WE SUMMARIZE THE
VARIOUS --
TAXES AND AND FEES THAT WERE
INCREASE THE SP ONE I WON'T GO
THROUGH ALL OF THEM SINCE I'M
SURE YOU'RE YOU'RE FAIRLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE PACKAGE --
BUT BROADLY SPEAKING --
SP ONE INCREASED GAS GAS TAXES
DIESEL TAXES.
AS WELL AS CREATED IN YOU
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT FEE
ON VEHICLES AND I ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE FEE --
IF YOU THESE --
THIS CHARGER STARTED TAKING A
FACT AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN ON IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
AND IF YOU LOOK THE LAST COLUMNS
OF THE FIGURE WE SHOW THE
ESTIMATED ANNUAL REVENUES FROM
SP.
ONE IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
IT'S ESTIMATED AT FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION --
GROWING IN A COUPLE YEARS TO A
LITTLE OVER FIVE BILLION
ANNUALLY.
I'M THE REASON WHY INCREASES IS
THAT NOT ALL OF THE CHARGES HAVE
TAKEN EFFECT YET.
ON AND ALSO THE CHARGES ARE
INDEXED FOR INFLATION IN THE
FUTURE SO THAT'S THAT'S WHY THEY
THINK GROW.
IN THE OUT YEARS.
SO REGARDING THE INITIATIVE
MEASURE WE DESCRIBED ON PAGE
THREE OF THE HANDOUT IT'S AN
AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION --
ESSENTIALLY DOES TWO THINGS.
THE FIRST IS THAT REQUIRES THE
LEGISLATURE TO GET VOTER
APPROVAL FOR SPECIFIED FUELING
VEHICLE TAXES.
AND SPECIFICALLY THE SUPPLIES TO
TAXES ON THE SALE STORAGE USE
AND CONSUMPTION OF GASOLINE AND
DIESEL FUEL.
IT ALSO APPLIES TO TAXES PAID
FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF OPERATING A
VEHICLE ON PUBLIC HIGHWAYS.
AND SUCH AS VEHICLE LICENSE FEES
THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER AS WELL
AS TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT
FEES WHICH WERE CREATED BY S.
B..
THE SECOND THING THE INITIATIVE
MEASURE DOES IS IT ELIMINATES
RECENTLY ENACTED --
SUCH SUCH RECENTLY ENACTED FUEL
AND VEHICLE TAX IS.
A SPECIFICALLY IT WOULD APPLY.
TO ANY SUCH FEELING VEHICLE
TAXES AND ACTED BETWEEN JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THE
DATE THE MEASURE TAKES A FAT.
AND IF IT IS PASSED BY THE
VOTERS WOULD TAKE EFFECT IN
DECEMBER --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND SO SENSE SB
ONE WAS ENACTED IN APRIL.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THIS MEASURE
WOULD APPLY TO THE TAXES IN SP
[inaudible]
ONE AND ON THE LAST PAGE I
SUMMARIZE THE FISCAL AFFECTS
THAT OUR OFFICE --
HAS ESTIMATED WE THINK THERE'S
TWO MAIN FISCAL IMPLICATIONS
FROM THE INITIATIVE.
THE FIRST IS THAT WOULD
ELIMINATE TAX REVENUES FROM SP
--
ONE AND AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
OF THE SORT OF ONGOING IN THE
OUT YEARS THIS WOULD BE ROUGHLY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
AND LESS FUNDING --
IN THIS FUNDING MAINLY WOULD
HAVE SUPPORTED HIGHWAY AND ROAD
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR PROGRAMS
AS WELL AS TRANSIT PROGRAMS AND
SOME OTHER TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS --
THAT MEASURE THOUGH DOES NOT
AFFECT OTHER PROVISIONS THAT
WERE IN SB ONE IT REALLY REALLY
JUST WOULD ELIMINATE THE TAX
REVENUES SO S. B. ONE DID
CONTAIN SOME OTHER.
PROVISIONS REGARDING --
INCREASED ACCOUNTABILITY --
OVER TRANSPORTATION SPENDING IT
WOULD NOT AFFECT THOSE THOSE
PROVISIONS.
THE SECOND MAN FISCAL
IMPLICATION THAT WE SEE IS THAT
WOULD MAKE --
PASSAGE OF FUEL AND VEHICLE
TAXES IN THE FUTURE MORE
DIFFICULT AND THIS IS DUE TO THE
VOTER APPROVAL REQUIREMENT WOULD
BE ANOTHER STEP IN THE PROCESS
--
TO INCREASING TAXES SO COULD
MEAN LESS REVENUE THAN
OTHERWISE.
HOWEVER WHERE UNABLE TO ESTIMATE
THE EFFECTS OF THIS --
AS IT WOULD DEPEND ON FUTURE.
THE VOTERS WHICH WE CANNOT
PREDICT.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WERE -- WE
HAVE A SIMPLE PROCESS NOW ON TO
OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AND SO CAN HAVE PEOPLE COME
FORWARD TO THE MY RIGHT OVER
HERE AND MAKE THEIR COMMENTS.
AS THEY PLEASE SO --
EACH PERSON WILL BE ALLOWED A
COUPLE MINUTES.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND ENERGY
--
SO.
WHAT IS A WHY DON'T WE START
WHEN WE START WITH YOU DAVID?
IN ADDITION TO SELF AND NAM.
IF YOU'RE STATEMENT FOR TWO
MINUTES PLEASE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ACTED
EVENING NOW DAVID WILL FOR THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION I THINK WE'RE THE
ONLY ONE HERE IN FAVOR OF THE
MEASURE SO IT'S PROBABLY BEST
THAT I GO FIRST ANYWAY --
AGAIN THIS MEASURE WOULD REPEAL
THE GAS AND CAR TAX AND PUT IT
ANY FUTURE SOME MORE TAXES TO A
STATEWIDE VOTE OF THE PEOPLE.
MEMBERS SOMETIME THIS WEEK THE
GOVERNOR WILL SIGN A RECORD
HUNDRED AND THIRTY BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET WITH ANY BILLION
DOLLAR SURPLUS AT A TIME WHEN WE
ALREADY HAVE AMONG THE HIGHEST
GAS AND CAR TAXES.
IN THE NATION.
YES TAXES ARE TOO HIGH BUT
THAT'S NOT PRIMARILY THE REASON
WE'RE SUPPORTING THIS EFFORT.
WE OPPOSE THESE TAXES BECAUSE OF
THIS LEGISLATURE'S INABILITY TO
MANAGE THE DOLLARS TAXPAYERS
HAVE ENTRUSTED THEM.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS A CAP AND
TRADE FELONS HAVE BEEN DROPPED
INTO THE GENERAL FUND THE LAST
FIVE YEARS. TEN BILLION DOLLARS
A TRUCK WAIT FEES OVER THE LAST
DECADE HAVE BEEN DIVERTED FROM
AWAY FROM MAINTAINING AND
REPAIRING OUR ROADS.
KEYMOD AWAY MEMBERS GENERAL FUND
SPENDING HAS INCREASED BY FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS WITH NOT ONE DIME AGAIN
NOT ONE DIME.
GOING TO TRANSPORTATION.
MEMBERS IN CLOSING WE ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITHTHE OPPONENTS OF THIS
MEASURE THAT OUR ROADS NEED TO
BE REPAIRED AND THAT WE DO
INDEED HAVE A FORTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR ROAD MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG. FOR THAT PROBLEMS THE
LEGISLATURE'S TO FIX USING
EXISTING RECORD HIGH REVENUES
AND SHOULD NOT BE A BURDEN TO
HARD WORKING CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS THINK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK REPLACE YOUR
AT GOOD GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIRMAN BRIAN ANA SECRETARY THE
STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
AND STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
IS COMPLETED THE FIRST
PROGRAMMING OR WAR AWARD ROUND
FOR SP ONE WITH OVER FIVE
THOUSAND PROJECTS APPROVED TO
RECEIVE S. B. ONE FUNDING.
AND THAT JUST COVERS THE FIRST
COUPLE YEARS.
WE EXPECT THOUSANDS MORE
PROJECTS TO BE FUNDED WITH SP
ONE OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
NOW THAT WE KNOW THE AWARDED
PROJECTS WE HAVE A BETTER IDEA
OF WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF THE
REPEAL MAJOR WERE TO PASS.
THOUSANDS OF SAFETY AND
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS ON LOCAL
ROADS FILLING POTHOLES FIXING
PAVEMENT MAKING CROSSWALKS MORE
SAFE.
WOULD NOT OCCUR.
HUNDREDS OF HIGHWAY BRIDGES
WOULD NOT RECEIVE SAFETY REPAIRS
REPLACEMENT.
THOUSANDS OF MILES OF PAPER
REPAIR WOULD NOT OCCUR ON STATE
HIGHWAYS.
TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECTS TO
ADDRESS COMMUTER AND FOR A
CONGESTION WOULD NOT OCCUR OR
THE SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED.
PROJECTS SUCH AS BART TO SAN
JOSE.
SACRAMENTO HIGHWAY FIFTY HOV
LANES AND WHY RAIL IMPROVEMENTS.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIAN PRUNE AND
STUFF HIGHWAYS FIVE TEN FIFTY
SEVEN ONE ON ONE AND OTHERS.
VERY IMPROVEMENTS TO HIGHWAY ONE
OR WHAT ONE A ONE SMART IN
CALTRAIN.
CENTRAL VALLEY IMPROVEMENTS TO
HIGHWAY NINETY NINE AND RAIL
INVESTMENTS AND LOS ANGELES
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPICS
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
MANY WOULD LIKELY BE DELAYED
UNTIL AFTER THE GAMES OCCUR.
THE BOTTOM LINE.
IF THE REPEAL WERE TO OCCUR
PAVEMENT WOULD GET WORSE INSTEAD
OF BETTER.
SAFETY PROJECTS WOULD BE
DEFUNDED.
AND PEOPLE AND THE ECONOMY WOULD
NOT BENEFIT FROM CONGESTION
RELIEF INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT BAKER PUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
NAME IS ASSISTANT CHIEF RICH
DESMOND REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
IT'S THE JOB THE CHP TO BE OUT
ON THE ROADWAYS EVERY DAY
KEEPING CALIFORNIAN SAFE AND I
CAN TELL YOU FROM MY EXPERIENCE
MY TWENTY THREE YEARS OF THE
CHP.
AS WELL AS IN THE EXPERIENCE OF
EVERY OTHER CHP OFFICER.
THAT KEEPING OUR ROADS
MAINTAINED IS CRITICAL TO
KEEPING MOTOR SAFE ON OUR
ROADWAYS.
THE CHP IS CONFIDENT THAT
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE TAKING
PLACE RIGHT NOW ON OUR ROADS
FREEWAYS AND BRIDGES.
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WOULD RESULT IN A NEWER MORE
MODERN TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
THAT WILL BE SAFER FOR MOTORISTS
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS AND OTHER FIRST
RESPONDERS.
AND INVESTMENT IN TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS LIKE THESE IS AN
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC SAFETY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIRMAN MANY MRS IN BRANSON I
SERVICE YOU EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
I IT OVER THE LAST DECADE THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION HEADED BY SO
LEGISLATURE ON THE NEED. TO
SECURE THE THE NECESSARY IN
STABILIZING NECESSARY
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING.
OTHERS SAID ARE CONCERNED THAT
THE COMMISSION HAD CAME TO
REALITY IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WHEN THE
COMMISSION ON CALIFORNIA WAS
FACED WITH A ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING SHORTFALL.
THAT FORCE A TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TO DE PROGRAM AND
DELAY PROJECTS THAT WE'RE HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN COMMITTED FOR A
STATE FUNDING.
IN THE STATE TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM.
THIS SHORTFALL MEANT THAT THE
COMMISSION NOT ONLY REMOVED
PREVIOUSLY COMMITTED FUNDING
FROM HUNDREDS OF PROJECTS.
IT ALSO MEANT THAT NOT A SINGLE
NEW PROJECT TO IMPROVE THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
COULD BE ADDED OVER THE FIVE
YEARS THAT STATE TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM.
AS OF THE COMMISSION'S MAY
MEETING THIS YEAR THE COMMISSION
HAS DEDICATED OVER NINE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO PROJECTS
THAT WILL PROVIDE BENEFITS TO
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
THOUSANDS OF PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED TO FIX BRIDGES
HIGHWAYS REPAIRMAN EIGHTEEN OVER
FOUR THOUSAND LOCAL STREETS AND
ROADS.
REDUCE CONGESTION IN THE MOST
CONGESTED CORRIDORS OF THE
STATE.
PROVIDE FOR SAFE ROUTES TO
SCHOOLS IMPROVE AND EXPAND
TRANSIT IN MORE.
THE COMMISSION HAS ALSO ADOPTED
IN IS ALREADY EXERCISING STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND
OVERSIGHT. TO ENSURE THAT FUNDS
ARE APPROPRIATELY AND
EFFECTIVELY SPENT AND ACCOUNTED.
FOR WITHOUT THE REVENUES
PROVIDED BY SENATE BILL ONE WE
KNOW THERE ARE INSUFFICIENT
FUNDS TO MAINTAIN OUR BRIDGES
HIGHWAYS.
LOCAL STREETS ROSE TRANSIT BY
PROTESTING FIELDS FACILITIES AND
MORE.
CRITICALLY NEEDED PROJECTS WILL
HAUNT.
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE WILL
CONTINUE TO DETERIORATE.
JOBS WILL BE LOST AND THE
ECONOMY ENVIRONMENT AND QUALITY
OF LIFE WILL BE AFFECTED FOR
THIS IN FUTURE GENERATIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I JUST LLOYD PEREIRA A MY COUNTY
SUPERVISOR FROM THE COUNTY
MERCED SERVING DISTRICT.
FOR AND THINK YOU FOR A
CONVENING THIS HEARING.
UP MERCED COUNTY --
TAKES A TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AS A HIGH
PRIORITY --
WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
MAINTENANCE OF SIXTEEN HUNDRED
MILES OF ROAD.
OUR ROAD SYSTEM IS DETERIORATED
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS DUE
TO LACK OF FUNDING.
THE THE COUNTY IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST AGRICULTURAL PRODUCERS
IN CALIFORNIA AND NOT ONLY THAT
BUT OUR NATION.
AND THE ARE CRUMBLING OF THE
ROADS IN THE DETERIORATION AYE
IS A IS A HEAVY ECONOMIC A
BURDEN THAT --
ARE FARMERS OF PAY AND AND THE
COST OF TRANSPORTING THEIR CROPS
TO MARKET --
I ASSUME THAT MOST OF THE PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA LIKE TO EAT APPLES
PEACHES AND GRAPES AND IF YOU
CAN IMAGINE --
THOSE OF FRUITS BEEN HOLD OVER
HOLES --
THEY THE PACK OUT IS ABOUT 18%
LESS THAN IT WOULD BE IF THEY
WERE DRIVEN ON A SMOOTH ROAD SO
IT'S A HIGH BURDEN FOR OUR
FARMERS SAT AT TO PAY.
SP ONE PROVIDES A STEADY FUNDING
SOURCE OF FOR THE REPAIR
REHABILITATION AND
RECONSTRUCTION OF THE OF MERCED
COUNTY ROAD SYSTEM.
A WE ARE PROJECTED TO REACH SIX
US RECEIVE SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION A DOLLARS IN THE UP
COMING FISCAL YEAR.
AND THAT'LL ALLOW US TO REPAIR
THIRTY THREE MILES OF ROAD.
WHICH WILL TAKE US FORTY EIGHT
YEARS TO GET THROUGH OF THE
ROADS AND MERCED COUNTY SO HAVE
I I THINK WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR THE MONEY --
THE DEDICATED FUNDING PROVIDED
BY S. B. WON WILL ALLOW US TO
DEVELOP A LONG TERM PAVEMENT
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM TO IMPROVE
THE OVERALL CONDITION OF THE
COUNTY'S ROAD SYSTEM.
IF SB ONE IS REPEALED WE WILL BE
FACED AND LAYING OFF A PORTION
OF OUR ROAD MAINTENANCE STAFF
WHICH WOULD SEVERELY IMPACT OUR
ABILITY. TO PRODUCE A PROVIDE
BASIC ROAD MAINTENANCE --
OVER THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS AND
THAT INCLUDES TIMELY PATCHING
POTHOLES STRIPING AND STENCILING
OF COUNTY ROADS AND SCHOOLS
OWNS.
DELAYED REPLACEMENT OF MISSING
DAMAGE OR TERRY DID ROAD SIGNS
MAINTENANCE REPAIRS OF THE
SHOULDERS SO WITHOUT A S. B. ONE
IT WOULD PUT OUR COUNTY AT A
SEVERE DISADVANTAGE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANKS FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
MERCED.
I WAS A FORMER COUNTY SUPERVISOR
[inaudible]
YES SIR.
HOW GOOD EVENING?
SENATOR BILL AND AND COMMITTEE
I'M JAY SPURGEON I'M THE PUBLIC
WORKS DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY OF
THOUSAND OAKS FOR ABOUT A
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
POPULATION JUST NORTH OF LA
COUNTY VENTURA COUNTY.
YOU KNOW OUR ROAD NETWORK IS THE
HIGHEST VALUE INFRASTRUCTURE THE
CITY OWNS AND I WOULD SAY THAT'S
TRUE FOR EVERY SITTING COUNTY IN
THE STATE.
THE VALUE OF THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
IS SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND WE CANNOT TEAM YOU TO
IGNORE.
MAINTAINING THAT VITAL ASSET I
MEAN THINK ABOUT EVERY DAY
RESIDENTS AND BUSINESS OWNERS.
TOUCH OUR STREETS MULTIPLE TIMES
EVERY DAY. TO MAINTAIN OUR THREE
INNER NEEDY MILES OF STREETS WE
NEED ABOUT SIX AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR.
WE HAVE A FOREIGN A HALF MILLION
DOLLAR PER YEAR GAP.
SP ONE PROVIDES FOR THE CITY
THOUSAND OAKS. THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR GOING FORWARD
FOR THE NEXT TEN YEARS THAT IS A
HUGE.
STOP IN OUR GAP.
AND THAT YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT IN
THE NEXT TEN YEARS WITHOUT THAT
FUNDING.
THE CONDITION OF OUR ROADS WILL
DROP.
BY WELL OVER TEN POINTS THE
RELATIVE KIND OF THING BUT
CLEARLY THAT'LL HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT TO THE
QUALITY ALIVE IN THE ECONOMIC
VITALITY AND SEE THOUSAND OAKS.
TODAY WE STARTED PAVING
REPAIRING STREETS IN THE
DARLINGTON NEIGHBORHOOD THREE
THREE MILES OF STREETS IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD.
I AND THAT'S JUST OF PART OF A
LARGER PROJECT THAT WE WORKING
ON THIS SUMMER.
AND INTO THE FALL OVER FIFTY
MILES STREETS WERE GONNA BE ABLE
TO RESURFACE REPAVE SLURRY SEAL
[inaudible]
THAT'S IN.
THAT'S THANKS TWO PARTIAL
FUNDING FROM SB ONE SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND FOR HEARINGS TO THE SECULAR
MUCH.
OF A NICK SPEAKER PLEASE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A GOOD AFTER
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS LISA AND
RAP AND I'M THE PUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY OF
LAKEWOOD.
I ALSO REPRESENT OVER FOUR
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC WORKS ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHO ARE ALREADY IMPLEMENTING
PROJECTS FUNDED THROUGH SB ONE
AND I REPRESENT THE GATEWAY
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS CITIES AS
OUR REPRESENTATIVE TO THE METRO
TAP?
LAKE WOULD IS LOCATED IN SOUTH
LOS ANGELES SOUTHEAST LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND SERVES A
POPULATION OF ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED SIX GENERAL I'M MILES OF
STREETS.
PRIOR TO SP ONE WE RECEIVED JUST
OVER ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS OF STATE TRANSPORTATION
REVENUE ANNUALLY.
SP ONE IS ESTIMATED TO PROVIDE
AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION PER YEAR MORE THAN
DOUBLE.
UP ALL OF WHICH IS PROGRAM FOR
PAVING OUR STREETS AND IMPROVING
DRAINAGE AND STORM WATER QUALITY
OF ON ONE OF OUR MAJOR STREETS.
WITHOUT SP ONE FUNDING A ONE
MILLION DOLLAR LEVERAGED GRANT
WOULD BE AT RISK IN OUR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM FOR STREETS
WOULD ESSENTIALLY BE STOPPED.
WE WOULD JUST WE JUST COMPLETED
A NEW PAVEMENT MANAGEMENT SURVEY
AND THE RESULTS TELL US THAT WE
NEED TO PLAN ON SPENDING ABOUT
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR FOR THE NEXT FIFTEEN
YEARS. TO KEEP OUR STREETS AND
GOOD STATE OF REPAIR WE NEED SP
ONE FUNDING TO GET THIS WORK
DONE.
IN FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
GATEWAY CITIES CAN --
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS BOARD
TOOK A POSITION OF UNANIMOUS
OPPOSITION TO THE REPEAL OF SB
ONE THE LOSS OF THESE FUNDS
WOULD DERAIL PROJECTS LARGE AND
SMALL.
THAT WOULD IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF LIFE IN OUR SUFFERS FROM
CHRONIC UNDER INVESTMENT AND
DISINVESTMENT.
THE IMPACTS OF LOSING SB ONE OF
THE GATEWAY CITIES WOULD INCLUDE
THE INTERSTATE SIX OH FIVE STATE
ROUTE NINETY ONE INTERCHANGEABLY
MEANT.
A GATEWAY CITIES FOR A
CROSSROADS THE ESTIMATED COST OF
A HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION AND THE THIRTY TWO
MILLION SP ONE FUNDS.
IN DISCRETIONARY ALLOCATION THAT
WILL ALLOW THE PROJECT TO
ADVANCE TO CONSTRUCTION ALSO THE
WEST SANTA ANA BRANCH LIKE REAL
WOULD BE SEVERELY IMPACTED ALL
WITH THE LOSS OF SB ONE FUNDS.
SO IN CLOSING THE PUBLIC WORKS
PROFESSIONALS AND A PW A MEMBERS
ACROSS A WIDE SPECTRUM OF DUTIES
ARE WORKING TOO HARD TO
IMPLEMENT PROJECTS TO IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK.
SP ONE IS CRITICAL IS A CRITICAL
PART OF THE FUNDING FOR THOSE
PROJECTS AND WITHOUT IT CITIES
COUNTIES AND STATE WILL SEE A
CONTINUED DETERIORATION OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU [inaudible]
POLICE.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME'S TRICIA
TILTS AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC WORKS FOR NEVADA COUNTY.
WE MAINTAIN ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY MILES OF ROADWAY.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN WE
REALIZED WE HAD OF A FUNDING
CRISIS ON OUR HANDS ARE FUNDING
WAS DOWN 30% OST OF INCREASED
20%.
WE COULDN'T DO ANY PAVEMENT
PRESERVATION PROJECTS AND WE
COULDN'T REPLACE EQUIPMENT SOME
OF THE EQUIPMENT WE HAVE IS
OLDER THAN I AM.
AND TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
SP ONE PASSED I WE WERE FINALLY
ABLE TO SCHEDULE PROJECTS
SCHEDULE QUIT ME REPLACEMENT.
THIS YEAR IN FACT TODAY WE JUST
STARTED OUR FIRST PAVEMENT
PRESERVATION PROJECT IN MANY
YEARS.
IF S. B. ONES REPEAL THE HALL
HAVE TO SUSPEND OPEN POSITIONS
IN MY ROAD DEPARTMENT ALL HAVE
TO SUSPEND ANY EQUIPMENT
REPLACEMENT WILL HAVE TO
ELIMINATE ALL FUTURE PROP.
OF PAVEMENT PRESERVATION
PROJECTS.
I'M CONTINUING OUR ROADS WILL
CONTINUE TO DETERIORATE.
I WILL PROBABLY NO LONGER BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN ANY F MY
UNPAVED ROADS WHICH IS ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILES OF
ROADWAY.
WILL HAVE A REDUCE LEVELS OF
LEVEL OF SERVICE THROUGHOUT.
SO FUNDING A FUNDING SOLUTION IS
NEEDED SP ONE CURRENTLY FILLS
THAT GAP.
AND THEN I HAVE A QUESTION YOU
KNOW IF WE ARE ALL TO CONTINUE
OUR EFFORTS TO WORK TOWARDS
CALIFORNIA'S GOAL OF ZERO
FATALITIES HOME I SUPPOSED TO DO
THAT WITHOUT FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING CAN STONE OF STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF SAN BENITO
COUNTY WHO ALSO OPPOSES AT THE
REPEAL OF SENATE BILL.
ONE I SEEM TO NEED A COUNTY IS
OVERNIGHT IN HER WORK WHO YOU
REPRESENT I SAN BENITO COUNTY
OKAY.
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
VOTED TO OPPOSE THE REPEAL.
WE ARE AS YOU KNOW --
ARE RURAL COUNTY BUT LOCATED IN
BETWEEN SAN JOSE AND MONTEREY I
IN ADDITION TO A LARGE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY WHO NEEDS
WORKING I'M ROAD STATEMENT TOM
MOVED TO PRODUCE THAT WE ALL
ENJOY.
ON A NUMBER OF WORKERS WHO WORK
IN SILICON VALLEY A HAVE.
MOVED TO SAN BENITO COUNTY AND
INCREASING TRAFFIC COMMUTER
TRAFFIC AYE AND WE NEED --
TO FUNCTIONING ROADS WE ACTUALLY
NOT ONLY NEED THE ONES REPAIRED
BUT WE NEED --
EXPANSION AND I ASSISTANCE TO
HELP WITH THOSE CONGESTION
ISSUES AND FOR THOSE REASONS
OPPOSE THE REPEAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY MOM'S FROM SAN BENITO COUNTY
ALRIGHT AND SHE WENT TO HIGH
SCHOOL HOLLISTER.
MOM'S PROBABLY WATCHING THAT'S
WHAT I SAID.
SHE WATCHED HIS NINETY ONE YEARS
OLD SHE LIKES TO WATCH ME ON THE
THE CHASER ALSO JUST
[inaudible]
HI MOM.
OKAY GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING I'M JAMIE BAUER THE
MARKETING AND LEGISLATIVE
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR SOLANO
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY --
START SOLANO COUNTY STRONGLY
OPPOSES THE REPEAL OF SP ONE
BECAUSE OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
WOULD LOSE OVER THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
OF THIS PRIMARY SOURCE OF STATE
FUNDS TO REPAIR POTHOLES AND ARE
ALREADY DEGRADED PAVEMENT. TO
INTERN FIFTY FOUR LOCAL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS ARE
STARTING THIS SUMMER.
SOLANO COUNTY WHICH IS THE HEART
OF THE MEGA REGION BETWEEN SEVEN
SAYS.
SENATE CISCO IN SACRAMENTO ALSO
LOSE THE FIFTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS JUST AWARDED BY THE CTC.
FOR IMPROVEMENTS OF THE I EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY HIGHWAY TWELVE
INTERCHANGE OF FAIRFIELD.
INFAMOUSLY KNOWN AS CORDELIA
JUNCTION THE BOTTLE NECKS AT
EVERY RUSH HOUR.
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR THIS
INTERCHANGE WILL NOT MATERIALIZE
TO COMPLETE FURTHER IMPROVEMENTS
AS WELL AS THE SOLANO PORTION OF
THE BAY AREA EXPRESS HIGH
OCCUPANCY VEHICLE LANES.
THE GO THROUGH FAIRFIELD IN
VACAVILLE.
WE WILL LOSE THE TEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS JUST AWARDED FOR
SOLANO REGIONAL TRANSIT
IMPROVEMENTS BUSES OPERATIONS
AND NEW STOPS TO SERVE OUR
COMMUTERS. SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN CALTRANS SHOP
PROJECTS ON HIGHWAY TWELVE IN
RIO VISTA WILL VANISH.
THE BAY AREA JUST APPROVED
REGIONAL MEASURE THREE WHICH
WILL BRING BRIDGE TOLL REVENUE
TO SOLANO COUNTY. FOR BUILDING
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH WE
INTEND TO USE OF MATCHING FUNDS
TO SUPPORT THESE PROJECTS.
THAT WOULD LOSE THEIR FUNDING BY
ELIMINATING S. B..
ONE SOLANO COUNTY LIKE THE REST
OF THE STATE CANNOT AFFORD TO
CONTINUE DOWN THE PATH OF
CRUMBLING INFRASTRUCTURE WITH NO
END IN SIGHT.
SP ONE IS CRUCIAL TO OUR
ECONOMIC VITALITY.
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE ITS REPEAL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BIGGER PLEASE.
GOOD EVENING SENATOR DEAL AND
MEMBERS OF CAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME'S ROBERT ARMY HOLE ON
THE CITY ENGINEER FOR THE CITY
OF TRACY AN ASSISTANT DIRECTOR
OF DEVELOPMENT SERVICES --
I HAD --
MANY QUESTIONS FROM OUR CITY
COUNCIL ON CONCERNS --
SHOULD THE S. B. ONE FUNDING --
BE --
ELIMINATED --
I HAVE FIVE HUNDRED SIX FIVE
MILLION MILES OF ROADS IN THE
CITY OF TRACY --
IN THIS YEAR WE STAND TO LOSE
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND AND DOLLARS
AND FUNDING WHICH IT WOULD
DOUBLE OUR A BUDGET OF FOUR OF
ROAD REPLACEMENT AND
REHABILITATION.
AND FOR THE UPCOMING YEAR WE
WOULD LOSE ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS A QUADRUPLING
OF OUR BUDGET.
ARE WE PROJECT THAT OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS THAT WE WOULD --
WE WOULD BE.
I NEEDING SEVENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS --
FOR PREVENTIVE AND
REHABILITATION BACKLOG --
FOR OUR ROADWAYS SO WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN TO THE FUNDING SHOULD WE
LOSE THIS WELL NEEDED A
SUPPLEMENT.
ALSO AND THE MAY MEETING OF THE
CDC WE ARE AWARDED THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS A TEA SET
FUNDING.
AND MY CITY COUNCIL IS VERY
WORRIED ABOUT WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN
--
TO THAT FUNDING THAT PROJECT
WOULD SUPPORT A INTERCHANGE
PROJECT FOR ARE A VERY IMPORTANT
INTERNATIONAL PARK OF COMMERCE
PROJECT.
WHICH IS A ARE CURRENTLY HAVE A
FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION SQUARE
FOOT --
TOTAL PROJECTS THAT INCLUDES
LIGHT INDUSTRIAL AND FOR FILM AT
CENTERS.
AND SUPPORTS THREE THOUSAND JOBS
CURRENTLY AND THAT'S ON A A
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED ACRE SITE --
WHICH WILL BUILD OUT --
TO THIRTY ONE MILLION SQUARE
FEET OF LIGHT INDUSTRIAL AND FOR
PHILMONT CENTERS.
ON AND BUILDS OUT --
TO THIRTY THOUSAND JOBS SO THIS
FUNDING AS WELL NEEDED FOR OUR
CITY AND WE WOULD WE ARE
DEFINITELY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL LOSS OF FUNDING THANK
YOU FOR HEARING MY COMMENTS I
APPRECIATE.
ALL YOU DO PERFECT MIX SPEAKER
PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY MY
NAME IS JESSICA EPSTEIN
REPRESENTING THE SAN MATEO
COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT.
THE TRANSIT DISTRICT OPERATES
SAMTRANS THE SAN MATEO COUNTY
BUSTIN PARA TRANSIT SERVICE AND
MANAGES CALTRAIN AND THE SAN
MATEO COUNTY TRANSPORTATION.
OUR REGION AS AN ECONOMIC ENGINE
VITAL TO THE STATE'S ECONOMY BUT
WE SUFFER UNDER EVER INCREASING
TRAFFIC CONGESTION.
REPEAL PUTS CRITICAL CONGESTION
RELIEF AND SAFETY PROJECTS.
IN JEOPARDY.
S. B. ONE IS SENT TO THE SECTOR.
FUND A HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
POINT A HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION TOWARDS COMPLETION
OF CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION PLUS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE POINT TWO MILLION TOWARDS
THE ONE ON ONE MANAGE LEANS
PROJECT WHICH HAS ALLOWED US TO
LEVERAGE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND PRIVATE SECTOR INVESTMENT TO
COMPLETE THIS PROJECT. FIFTEEN
MILLION TO LAUNCH AN EXTRA
REGIONAL EXPRESS BUS SYSTEM.
AS WELL AS A IS SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND FOUR
REDOING THE LINN OF OUR PARKING
RIGHT WHICH IS A CRITICAL
TRANSIT HUB FOR OUR COASTAL
RESIDENTS WHO OFTEN FEEL
ISOLATED AND NEED THIS --
REDEVELOPMENT OF THEIR TRANSIT
HUB.
WE HAVE MANY MORE PROJECTS
FUNDED BY SP ONE AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION ON THIS MATTER.
THE GERMAN BILL CHAIRMAN FRAZIER
MICHAEL TURNER ON BEHALF OF THE
METRO BOARD OF DIRECTORS THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS IS OPPOSED TO
ANY EFFORT.
TO REPEAL THIS VITAL
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE YOU A LIST OF THE
PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS THAT WILL
RECEIVE FUNDING IN LA COUNTY.
FIXING POTHOLES IN EVERY CITY IN
LA COUNTY THERE'S EIGHTY EIGHT
CITIES IN THE COUNTY FIXING
IMPROVING COMMUTES ON HIGHWAYS
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
EXTENDING THE GOAL LINE AMONG
CLEAR EXTENDING THE GREEN LINE
THROUGH THE SOUTH BAY TO
TORRANCE.
BUILDING A NEW RAIL LINE FROM
DOWNTOWN LA TO THE GATEWAY
CITIES AREA BUILDING A NEW RAIL
LINE IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
IMPROVING--
SERVICE ON THE ORANGE LINE IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CONNECTING RAIL TO THE AIRPORT
IN IMPROVING I FIVE IN THE SANTA
CLARITA VALLEY.
RELIEVING CONGESTION AT SOME OF
THE WORST CHOKE POINTS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SUCH AS A FIFTY
SEVEN SIXTY INTERCHANGE STATE
ROUTE SEVENTY ONE IN THE SIX OH
FIVE NINETY ONE INTERCHANGE.
MEASURE WILL ALSO --
IMPROVE TRAFFIC CONDITIONS
AROUND THE LA LONG BEACH PORT
COMPLEX SUPPORT AND EXPAND THE
FREEWAY SERVICE PATROL AND
SUPPORT THE CONVERSION OF OUR
BUSES TO OUR BUS FLEET. TWO ZERO
MISSION ALL THESE PROJECTS AND
PROGRAMS WILL BE AT RISK IF SP
ONE IS IS REPEAL THANK YOU.
NOW GETTING ME MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CHARLIE SWANLEY ON THE PUBLIC
WORKS DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY OF
LODI.
I'M HERE TO VOICE OUR OPPOSITION
TO THIS INITIATIVE FOR THE
ELIMINATING FUNDING FOR LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS IN EVERY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY.
THE CITY OF LODI HAS MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED LANE MILES OR TWO
HUNDRED MILES OF STREETS AND ON
AVERAGE SPENDS APPROXIMATELY
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS EACH YEAR ON STREET
MAINTENANCE.
WHICH IS DEFINITELY NOT ENOUGH.
FUNDING TO PROPERLY MAINTAIN OUR
STREETS HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY
SCARCE AND ALTHOUGH WE
CONSISTENTLY SEEK MORE COST
EFFECTIVE METHODS OF ROAD
MAINTENANCE.
THE CONDITION OF OUR ROADWAYS
CONTINUE TO SUFFER.
S. B. ONE ENABLE CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO ADDRESS SIGNIFICANT
MAINTENANCE AND REHABILITATION
NEEDS ON OUR LOCAL STREETS AND
ROADS THE CITY OF LODI.
IS SET TO RECEIVE NEARLY
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS OVER
TEN YEARS NOW WILL DEFINITELY
BE.
NEEDED OVER TO TO REPAIR PARA
ROADS THAT ARE IN POOR
CONDITION.
THE FUNDING IS BADLY NEEDED TO
PERFORM THE NEED TO PAYMENT
MINUTES ON A ROAD NET NETWORK.
WE'VE ALREADY PROGRAM TO LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS THIS
YEAR WE'RE GOING TO RESURFACE
TWO AND A HALF MILES.
OF OUR MAJOR ARTERIALS USING A
PORTION OF SB ONE FUNDING.
AND NEXT YEAR WE HAVE PROGRAMMED
FIVE AND A HALF MILES OF
RESURFACING PROJECTS --
THAT OUR CITY COUNCIL HAS
APPROVED TO BE INCLUDED IN NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET.
BOTH OF THESE PROJECTS AS WELL
AS FUTURE RED MENACE PROJECTS
ARE AT RISK IF THIS.
INITIATIVE IS APPROVED.
THE CITY OF LUBBOCK SIMPLY CAN'T
AFFORD TO THE LAYER CUT.
THESE PROJECTS THAT WILL FINALLY
ALLOW US TO BEGIN PERFORMING
BADLY NEEDED ROAD MAINTENANCE
THAT HAS BEEN DEFERRED DUE TO
CONSISTENT FUNDING SHORTFALLS.
THIS SHORTSIGHTED INITIATIVE
WILL JEOPARDIZE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND COST TAXPAYERS MORE LONG RUN
AS ROAD CONDITIONS GET WORSE AND
WE KICKED REPAIRS BECOME MORE
EXPENSIVE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON STATURE MEMBERS
GOT SCORE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AGENCIES
FROM MONTEREY STANISLAUS SANTA
BARBARA IN MARIN.
KEEP MY COMMENTS I REALLY PRE
FABRICLIVE THE OPPOSED TO ANY
EFFORTS TO REPEAL SP.
ONE CLEARLY CAN'T I ADVOCATE
THAT WE CAN EDUCATE THE PUBLIC
ON THE BENEFITS OF THE
LEGISLATION.
AND PENDING BALLOT MEASURE ARE
JUST JUST TOO QUICK POINTS I
THINK -- AS
WERE TALKING TO THE PUBLIC WE
JUST HAVE TO CALL IT WHAT IT IS
AND IT'S A GAS TAX THE PUBLIC
DOESN'T KNOW WHAT S. B. ONE IS
SO.
THEY KNOW THAT THEY'RE PAYING
MORE IN GAS TAXES AND I THINK WE
HAVE TO MAKE MORE OF AN EFFORT
TO CONNECT THAT --
OF ARGUING WITH THE PUBLIC OUR
IS -- TO
TALK ABOUT ALL THE GREAT
BENEFITS I CLEARLY HAVE A LONG
LIST OF PROJECTS FOR MY CLIENTS
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM THANKS TO
THE PASSAGE OF SB.
ONE BUT IT'S REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE VALUE PROPOSITION THIS
OF MAINTAINING THAT
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING WATER MY
PAYING AS A TAXPAYER.
IFILL MY POTHOLES TO MAINTAIN
TRANSIT SERVICE TO REPAVE
HIGHWAYS OR LEVY CONGESTION.
AND I'VE DONE THE MATH THE COMES
UP TO FOURTEEN CENTS A DAY AND
SO IT'S FOURTEEN CENTS PER DAY
DOUBLE HAVING TO SPEND TO
MAINTAIN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS SO --
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT --
TOWARDS REPEALING THE SUFFERED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DILLON
THE HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WHERE
THAT MULTI MODAL TRANSIT AGENCY
AND HIGHWAY.
IMPROVEMENT --
AREA FOR THE HEART OF THE
SILICON VALLEY.
S. B. ONE MEANS OF MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR OFFICE
AND IT HELPS LEVERAGE ON THE
BART FACE TO PROJECT ALONE FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN LOCAL.
AND FEDERAL DOLLARS.
IT ALSO PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
MANAGE LANES ON THE ONE A ONE
ONE OF THE MOST AYE CONGESTED
CORRIDORS ON IN THE COUNTRY.
IT PROVIDES HELP OUR ON HIGHWAY
ONE A ONE AND STATE ROUTE TO
THIRTY SEVEN AT MATILDA IT
PROVIDES A HELP.
FOR INTERCHANGE AT WORK AT STATE
REP TWENTY FIVE AND ONE A ONE
JUST SOUTH OF GILROY THAT HELPS.
A DEAL WITH CONGESTION ON ONE OF
THE MOST BUSY AGRICULTURE
QUARTERS IN THE STATE.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST PROVIDES
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ESTIMATED
TO HELP STREETS AND ROADS WITHIN
OUR FIFTY CITIES A FIFTEEN
CITIES AND COUNTY. FOR THESE
REASONS WE HEARTILY SUPPORT AS
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR EFFORTS.
MCKINLEY THOMPSON MORLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN JOSE.
AS WE ONE IS CRITICAL AND
PROVIDES A LONG OVERDUE
INVESTMENT IN MAINTAINING AN
EXPANDING OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM.
ON THE MAIN INSIDE SP ONE
PROVIDE SEVENTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN SAN JOSE TO
REPAVE OUR STREETS AND HAS
HELPED REPAVE TWENTY THREE MILES
OF OUR ARTERIAL STREETS.
WE HAVE A NINETY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR ANNUAL PAVEMENT NEED AN
SP ONE FUNDS MOVE US IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
SB ONE ALSO INVESTING CRITICAL
IN. FOR PART FACE TO CALTRAIN
AND ONE A ONE EXPRESS LANES.
WE NEED A SP ONE TO CONTINUE
MAINTAINING AN EXPANDING OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM TO ME
RESIDENT NEEDS THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRS AND MEMBERS TIM SHOT
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT
WHERE BART PARTIES THE BACKBONE
OF THE TRANSIT SYSTEM IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
CARRYING SOME --
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND WEEKDAY
PASSENGER TRIPS --
EVERY WEEKDAY AND DURING THE
PEAK COMMUTE TIMES --
TWICE AS MANY PEOPLE TRAVEL
UNDER THE BAY THROUGH THE BAR
TEAM AS RIGHT OVER THE BAY ON
THE BAY BRIDGE CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF OUR TRANSIT SYSTEM
--
IF SB ONE IS REPEALED THE LOSS
OF STATE TRANSIT ASSISTANT FUNDS
ARE LIKELY TO HAVE A VERY DIRECT
IN SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON PARTS
ABILITY.
PROVIDE A REVENUE SERVICE --
INCLUDING CRITIC FUNDING
CRITICAL PREVENTIVE MAINTENANCE
EFFORTS SUCH AS ELEVATORS
ESCALATORS TRAIN CONTROL
ELECTRICAL AND MECHANICAL
TRACTION POWER INTEREST --
IS UNDOUBTEDLY WILL --
RESULT IN UNAVOIDABLE IMPACTS ON
SERVICE AND INFRASTRUCTURE IN A
MAINTENANCE.
LIKEWISE THE LOSS OF TI RCP
FUNDS IF S. B. ONE IS REPEALED
COULD HAVE A DIRECT EFFECT ON
BART'S ABILITY. TO REPLACE DE
TRAIN CARS THAT WERE CURRENTLY
IN THE PROCESS OF REPLACING
OLDEST.
TRAIN CARS IN THE NATION MORE
THAN FORTY YEARS OLD.
AND THE AND NEW TRAIN CONTROL
SYSTEM SO THAT WE CAN INCREASE
OUR CAPACITY.
AND THE BAY BRIDGE BY AS MUCH AS
30% -- ON
BEHALF THE COUPLE QUARTER JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY WHICH RUNS
INTERCITY RAIL SERVICE BETWEEN
THE SACRAMENTO REGION IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA --
IF S. B. ONE IS REPEALED IT WILL
LIKELY LEAD TO THE IMMEDIATE
CESSATION OF ALL EFFORTS
CURRENTLY UNDERWAY TO ENHANCE
CAPITOL COURT OR TRAIN SERVICE
TO SAN JOSE.
AND TO EXPAND TRAIN FREQUENCIES
TO ROSEVILLE --
TO TWENTY TRAINS DAILY THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING SIR CHAIR.
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
HI MY NAME IS STEVEN MACHIDA AND
PUB OR DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY OF
SAN CARLOS --
WE'RE SMALL COMMUNITY WERE
WITHIN THE SAN FRANCISCO
PENINSULA.
AS YOU WILL HEAR AND YOU HAVE
HEARD THAT THE ELIMINATION OF S.
B. ONES WILL HURT ALL CITIES WAY
TO STREETS AND TRANSPORTATION.
IN MY CASE MY NIECE AND OF OVER
TWO MILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR ON
ST MAIL BUT ST PROHIBIT
LOCATION.
ARE TO MAINTAIN ABOUT SEVENTY
MILES US A STREETS. FOR THE PAST
TWO YEARS WE'VE BEEN SPENDING
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OBVIOUSLY THAT THERE IS
A SHORTFALL ABOUT WHAT OVER A
FIVE ARE.
THOUSAND WHICH WE ANTICIPATE SP
ONE WOULD SERVE THAT GAP.
SO FOR EACH YEAR --
TO TO QUICKLY MAINTAIN THE
STREET.
DO YOU TO HAVE A DETERIORATION
OF OUR STREETS AND INCREASING
POSSIBLES.
ARE THIS PERSON ADDITIONAL
STRAIN ON THE QUALIFY FOR
COMMUNITY.
IMPACTS OUR ECONOMY AND JOB
CREATION.
EXPLOSIVE PUBLIC FOR ADDITIONAL
COST TO REPAIR COSTS AND AFFECTS
EMERGENCY RESPONSE PERSONNEL.
CITIES REALLY CANNOT AFFORD TO
LOSE A FUNDING SOURCE AND STILL
PROVIDE IMPORTANT SERVICE AT THE
COMMUNITY DEMANDS AND DESERVES
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING CHAIRS IN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M RAINY BRO PUBLIC
WORKS DIRECTOR OF THE CITY OF
BRISBANE.
I FIRST STARTED ADVOCATING IN
THE CAPITAL FOR AN INCREASE IN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN WHY OFFER
TESTIMONY DID SENATE'S
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING
COMMITTEES SPECIAL HEARING ON
THE STATE OF LOCAL BRIDGES THAT
HAVE BEEN CALLED AS A DIRECT
RESULT OF THE I THIRTY FIVE WEST
BRIDGE COLLAPSE IN MINNEAPOLIS.
WHICH KILLED THIRTEEN PEOPLE AND
INJURED ONE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
PEOPLE AS THEY WERE INVOLVED IN
THE MONDAY IN ACTIVE COMMUTING
HOME.
THE CHALLENGES BEFORE US IS MUCH
MORE THAN ONLY IN IN KIT
ECONOMIC INCONVENIENCE OF
POTHOLES DAMAGING VEHICLES.
AND CAUSING DELAYS TO COMMUTERS
IN MOVEMENT AFRAID.
WHEN WE FAIL TO PROPERLY INSTALL
AN APPROPRIATELY MAINTAIN OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE WE
KNOWINGLY CREATE SCENARIOS THAT
PLACE THE UNSUSPECTING TRAVELING
PUBLIC AT RISK OF INJURY?
A SYSTEM THAT IS NOT MAINTAIN
HAS BRIDGES TO COLLAPSE.
ROADWAYS THAT FAILED DURING
HEAVY RAINS.
AND INCREASED COLLISIONS BETWEEN
MOTORIZED VEHICLES AND
PEDESTRIANS AND BICYCLISTS.
AS A PUBLIC SERVANT RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE SAFETY OF CITIZENS USING
OUR ROADWAYS I STRONGLY OPPOSE
INITIATIVE TO ELIMINATE THIS
CRITICAL FUNDING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU TEARS IN MEMBERS
CHIANA CITY DAY ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
OPPOSED TO THE EFFORTS TO REPEAL
SP ONE AND THIS MEASURE IS
EXPECTED TO RESULT IN TWENTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS --
AWAY FROM THE COUNTY THAT WOULD
BE A USE FOR LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS ARE FOR
THOSE REASONS ALAMEDA CUTTING
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AT THE POST
OFFICE MEASURE THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS AT
THE SUPPORT THAT I AND I AM AN
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR UP WITH
EASY TRADE SAY.
WHICH SERVES THREE THIRTEEN
CITIES --
AND UNINCORPORATED AREAS AND
ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTIES WE ALSO PROVIDE BY
SERVER IS ACROSS THE DUMBARTON
BRIDGE THE BRIDGE AND HE WOULD
SEND MATTEO BRIDGE.
WE OUR SAFETY NET FOR ESP
RESIDENTS THINGS TO S. B. ONE WE
ANTICIPATE RECEIVING
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR OPERATING
ASSISTANCE AND CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS INCLUDING THE
PURCHASE A FORTY FIVE ZERO
EMISSION BUSES.
THIS WILL ALLOW US TO REPLACE
DIESEL POWERED BY SAYS THAT
OPERATE IN DESIGNATED
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT OAKLAND PRESERVING SP
ONE IS WHERE THE PROTECTING AS
MORE THAN PROTECTING FUNDING.
IS ENSURING THAT OUR FLEET OF
SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY BUSES
CONTINUE TO GET HARD WORKING
WRITERS TO THEIR JOBS ALL WHILE
DOING OUR PART TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THINK
YOU.
A GOOD EVENING STEVE AKIRA
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE HIGHWAY
TRANSPORTATION DISTRICT THE US
NUMBER AND EVERY REAL TRANSIT
DISTRICT NAPA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND THE
CALVARY BICYCLE COALITION.
WILL SUPPORT THE PRESERVATION OF
A SB -- ONE
THIS THESE ARE FUNDS THAT WILL
NOT ONLY PROVIDE --
MAGNETS AND AND SAFETY PERMITS.
BUT ALSO --
YOUR RELIEF CONGESTION EFFORTS
--
THROUGH TRASH FISH PROPERTIES
OPTIONS ON HOW WE WANNA ONES
WITH SMART EXPANSION.
BUT ALSO INVEST IN OUR YARD OUR
ECONOMY BY MAKING INVESTMENTS IN
--
IMPROVING THE ACCESS TO IT FROM
THE PORT OF OAKLAND --
SO WE URGE.
YOUR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT
RESCUE.
ONE GOOD EVENING I'M MARC WATTS
FIRST OF ALL I'M HERE TO REPORT
THAT TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA
URGES YOU TO OPPOSE.
THE ROAD REPAIR RATE WE HAVE
REALLY COME TO REALIZE HOW
IMPORTANT THIS I ASK YOU ONE HAS
TO THE SAFETY OF OF THE FUTURE
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIA MOTORISTS.
AND WE OPPOSE IT ARE ALSO
ACCUSED MENTION A COUPLE OF
HIGHLIGHTED --
PROJECTS FOR THREE DIFFERENT
COUNTIES.
IN THE COUNTY CONTRA COSTA THIS
OF REPEAL WOULD [inaudible]
A FACT.
THE EXPRESS THE IMPORTANT
EXPRESS LANES SOUTHBOUND --
PROJECT THAT'S THAT THAT WILL
CONNECT DIMINISH MARTINEZ BRIDGE
WITH BONTA CREEK ON SIX EIGHTY
AS WELL AS POSSIBLY INTERRUPT
THE PHASE THREE OF THE SIX
EIGHTY FOUR INTERCHANGE.
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY THERE ARE
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE LOCAL
STREETS AND ROAD PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BE JEOPARDIZED.
IN AS WELL AS THE SEVENTY ONE
NINETY ONE INTERCHANGE PROJECT.
THE I FIFTEEN EXPRESS LANES
EXTENSION ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT
AND OTHERS AND IN SAN FRANCISCO.
HAS A NUMBER OF FIVE PROJECTS TO
POINT TO BUT I THINK.
OUR FIRST AND FOREMOST WOULD BE
THE RESURFACING OF THIRTY NINE
MILES OF RESIDENTIAL ARTERIAL
STREETS ROUTES SAN FRANCISCO.
AND AS WELL --
DISRUPT THE CONSTRUCTION.
OF MANAGE LANES ON US ONE ONE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
THE GERMAN RECESS IDEAS ON
BEHALF OF THE FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL STRONGLY OPPOSED
THE REPEAL.
OF VITAL TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
--
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING THAT ALSO
CARRIED SIGNIFICANT REFORMS TO
HOW THESE THE PROJECTS ARE
DELIVERED A ONE OF THOSE REFORMS
OF COURSE IN PROPOSITION.
SIXTY NINE VERY IMPORTANT TO
PROTECT AND NOT HAVE ANY
COMPETITION WITH TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING OR EDUCATIONAL HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES.
IT ALSO INCLUDED OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ALL PEOPLE ACROSS THAT A
CALIFORNIA TO ACCESS A REWARDING
CAREER IN CONSTRUCTION TO PRE
APPRENTICESHIP SO RUN THE URGE.
YOUR STRONG OPPOSITION TO THAT
REPEAL THANK YOU.
CONTAINING OF FRED NO OR
REPRESENTING THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP IN WE HAVE LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE OPPOSE THAT REPEAL
OF SENATE BILL ONE AND STRONGLY
SO.
WE FEEL CONTINUED FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION IS VITAL FOR BOTH
SILICON VALLEY IN CALIFORNIA SO
THAT WE CAN KEEP.
OURSELVES VITAL AND GROWING
THANK YOU.
CURT BLACKMAN OF ELLISON WASN'T
ADVOCACY HERE ON BEHALF OF TO
CLIENTS TO BRIEFLY DISCUSS THE
POSITIVE IMPACTS THE S. B. ONE
HAS HAD ON THEIR COMMUNITIES.
FIRST AS SUCH SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS
SANDBAG.
IS USING AFTER ONE FUNDS TO
LEVERAGE.
THE SAN DIEGO REGION'S HALF CENT
SALES TAX IN ORDER DELIVER
DOZENS OF TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS TO THE REGION.
SPECIFICALLY MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS I WOULD ASK YOU PUNCH ES
DE ONE FUNDS ARE BEING USED TO
DELIVER THE FIRST PHASE OF THE
NORTH COAST CORNER PROJECT --
THIS IS A MAJOR PACKAGE OF RAIL
HIGHWAY.
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
ENVIRONMENTAL PROJECTS SPENDING
TWENTY SEVEN MILES ON
INTERSTATE.
FIVE SENATE IS ALSO USING SP ONE
FUNDS TO DELIVER MASSIVE
IMPROVEMENTS ALONG THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER --
WHICH WILL BENEFIT THE ECONOMY
THE ENVIRONMENT AND MOBILITY
THROUGHOUT THE REGION.
SECOND WE'RE ALSO HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LOCKING OUT A
FLINTRIDGE WHO RECEIVE THE
FOLLOWING FUNDING FROM SB.
ONE A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR MATCH
FOR CRITICAL MUCH NEEDED SOUND
WHILE PROJECT AND FOR HER
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
FUNDING FOR STREET RESURFACING.
AS YOU CAN SEE THESE ARE
CRITICAL PROJECTS IN ALL ARE
DIRECTLY DEPEND UPON SP ONE
FUNDS THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING COMMITTEE CHAIRED A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ERIC'S OUR
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION OVER THE
LIFE OF THE S. B. ONE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING PACKAGE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY
IS PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA'S GOODS
MOVEMENT CORRIDORS AND CONGESTED
CORRIDORS WERE C. TUNER
[inaudible]
FIFTY MILLION ANNUALLY.
THIS FUNDING IS CRITICAL FOR THE
SAFE AND EFFICIENT MOVEMENT OF
GOODS IN THE STATE AND WITH THE
FREIGHT DEMAND CONTINUE TO GROW
TO RAPID PACE REPEALING SP ONE
WOULD BE A HUGE STEP IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION.
AS AN INDUSTRY THAT CONTRIBUTES
MORE THAN THREE BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO THE STATE'S
INFRASTRUCTURE SEE SYSTEM CTA
WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB ONE
TRANSPORTATION FUND.
GOOD EVENING --
MICHAEL PIMENTEL WITH THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO'S
MAYOR AS WELL AS THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
ATTEMPT DISCUSS TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM FACES THE TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR FUNDING GAP OVER
THE NEXT TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
WE SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE A
VITAL FUNDING PROVIDED BY S. B..
ONE PARTICULAR FSB ONE REPEALED
WE'D LOSE THIRTY SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN
TRANSIT OPERATING FUNDS AS WELL
AS FUNDS FOR STATE OF GOOD
REPAIR.
AND TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO REPAIR OUR ROADS.
ADDITIONALLY IN THIS IS VERY
CRITICAL FOR US --
IF S. B. ONE WERE REPEALED I
WOULD LOSE TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME CONTENT OF
FUNDS THAT WILL BE USED TO
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION AND
MODERNIZATION.
OF OUR LIGHT RAIL FLEET.
GOOD EVENING SIR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M EDWARD ITTY
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
WORKS FOR THE CITY OF GLENDALE.
I'M HERE TO VOICE OVER
OPPOSITION OF THIS INITIATIVE TO
ELIMINATE FUNDING FOR LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
IN EVERY CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY.
IN FISCAL YOU SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
DODINSKY TO HAVE PROJECT IS
CURRENTLY UNDER CONSTRUCTION.
WITH ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN SP ONE FUNDING IS
BEING USED. FOR THE UPCOMING
YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FISCAL
YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO
PROJECT IN DESIGN PHASE THE SAN
FERNANDO.
THE ROAD AHEAD PROJECT TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS SB ONE IS
BEING USED.
AND HIGHLAND AVENUE WOULD HAVE
PROJECT ONE PUT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN SP ONE ALSO BEEN
USED.
FOR FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY THE CENTRAL
AVENUE BUT HE HAVE PROJECT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS SP ONE FUND WILL
BE USED AND SEE TO SURFACING AND
CAPES YOU PROJECT. FOR MILLION
DOLLARS SP ONE WOULD BE USED.
AS YOU KNOW THE PUBLIC COURTS
RELY HEAVILY ON ME FUND GRANTS
MEASURES AND PROPS AND WITHOUT
SP ONE FUND REVENUE.
THE CITY WILL GO BACK TO CATCH
UP MODE LEADING TO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
I'D USE GO BEFORE AN ELIMINATING
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PROJECT.
S. B. ONE HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE
SUCCESSFUL PROMISING.
FUNDING SOLUTION TO OVERSEE TO
BROADWAY AND PUBLIC SAFETY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS TO ADDRESS
THE SEE TO SURFACING.
COULD BETTER SIDEWALK.
REPAIRS AS WELL A. D. A.
ACCESSIBILITY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
GOOD EVENING CHAIRS MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE I'M MIKE WILEY.
AND I'M A VOLUNTEER MEMBER.
OF BRIEF CALIFORNIA SACRAMENTO
REGION.
OUR ONE OF OUR TOP PRIORITIES
MISSIONS A BRIEF CALIFORNIA IS
ADVOCATING FOR CLEANER
[inaudible]
REDUCE EMISSIONS.
IMPROVED AIR QUALITY AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
S. B. ONE FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO
ASSIST US IN ACHIEVING OUR
MISSION.
TURNING SACRAMENTO'S AIR INTO
CLEAN AIR.
WE SUFFER UNDER TOO MANY DAYS
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
YEAR OF UNREASONABLE AIR.
AIR QUALITY THAT HURTS.
THE ELDERLY IN THE YOUTH IN
PARTICULAR.
S. B. ONE IS CRITICAL FUNDING
THAT ALLOWS US IN OUR REGION. TO
IMPROVE OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM TO MAINTAIN OUR STREETS
AND ROADS TO PROVIDE
ACCESSIBILITY FOR PEDESTRIANS
AND ALTERNATIVE MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION FOR BICYCLISTS.
IT PROVIDES TREMENDOUS LEVEL OF
FUNDING TO ALLOW OUR TRANSIT
SYSTEM HERE IN SACRAMENTO. TO
CONTINUE TO GROW IT SYSTEM YOU
HEARD ABOUT PROJECT TO DOUBLE
TRACK SERVICE TO THE CITY OF
FOLSOM IT ALLOWS US TO CARRY
MANY MORE PEOPLE.
IN ALTERNATIVE TRANSPORTATION
AND GET THEM OUT OF CARS.
S. B. ONE PROVIDES CRITICAL
FUNDING FOR THE REHABILITATION
OF OUR SYSTEM [inaudible]
THROUGHOUT.
SACRAMENTO AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE NOT GONNA TALK ANYMORE
ABOUT SPECIFIC PROJECTS BUT I'M
GONNA URGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE THE REPEAL OF SP ONE FOR
AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
THAT ARE DESPERATELY NEEDED
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN
MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES OF CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF ENGINEERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO WORK
WITH THESE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
IN THE STATE THAT LED TO A
DELIVER.
THESE PROJECTS TODAY WE JOIN
THEM IN SUPPORTING SP ONE AND
OPPOSING THIS REPEAL EFFORT
LIKE.
GOOD EVENING OUT MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS TO ACCURATE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CITIES
REPRESENTING FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE US TO OF THE STATE
CITIES.
OF THE LEGISLATURE ARM AT YOU
DON'T DO IT EXERCISED A LOT OF
WISDOM LAST YEAR WHEN THEY
PASSED S. B. ONE WELL HAVING
LOOKED AT THE POLICY ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH TRANSPORTATION.
THE DECLINING CONDITION OF OUR
STREETS AND ROADS BOTH STATE
HIGHWAYS AS WELL AS LOCAL
STREETS AND ROADS.
I SP WANTS A CRITICAL INVESTMENT
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE AND A WE WE
CERTAINLY WOULD WE CERTAINLY
OPPOSE OF THE THE THAT THE THE
REPEAL OF SP ONE AND THINK IT'S
A GREAT INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL
FOR CALIFORNIA.
GOOD EVENING CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMISSION.
MY NAME IS BILL THE HEART TIME
ON THE CITY COUNCIL ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN THE CITY OF THE CITY
OF TURLOCK BECAUSE THAT.
I'M JUST HERE THIS EVENING
BECAUSE I I WANT TO VOICE OUR
PARTICULAR OPPOSITION.
POTENTIAL REPEAL OF US WE WANT.
IT ENABLES CITIES AND COUNTIES
FOR ONCE. TO HAVE A FUNDING
MECHANISM TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THE DEPLORABLE CONDITION OF OUR
ROADS.
I SEE HOW CAN HOW BAD CAN IT BE.
WELL ANY TYPE.
I WHEN WE WERE AT SIXTY FIVE OR
SEVENTY THREE YEARS AGO.
WITHOUT WHILE THAT'S PRETTY BAD.
AS OF THE THIRTY FIRST OF MAY OF
THIS YEAR IT'S FIFTY EIGHT WERE
DECLINING AT A RATE THAT FRANKLY
IS UNSUSTAINABLE.
NOW THAT WE HAVE A FUNDING
MECHANISM.
IT BECOMES EVEN MORE CRITICAL.
THAT WE BEGIN TO ADDRESS THOSE
NEEDS.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT TEN
YEARS SIXTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
NOW IN COMPARISON TO SOME OTHER
LARGER COMMITTEE SIXTEEN POINT.
FIVE IS CHUMP CHANGE.
BUT NOT US.
WE HAVE THIRTY THREE PROJECTS
CURRENTLY.
ON THE BOOKS.
THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING
CITY STREETS. TWO MAJOR
THOROUGHFARES TWO CONNECTORS.
AND THIS YEAR ALONE.
WILL BE SPENDING.
IN EXCESS OF EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND NEXT YEAR. SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND FOR A
TOTAL OF ABOUT.
A ONE POINT SIX IN THE FIRST TWO
YEARS.
BUT IT'S MORE THAN JUST.
THE THE PROJECTS THAT WE'VE GOT
LISTED.
WE ALSO HAVE TO GET NOW ASPHALT
TRUCKS AND HOT MIX AND PERSONNEL
TO OPERATE THE SAME.
THESE ARE ALL COMING.
FROM S. B. ONE FUNDS.
SO WHAT SHOULD BE ABSOLUTELY NO
DOUBT IT WENT UP TO TWO MINUTES
SHOULD BE ABSOLUTELY NO DOUBT.
THAT S. B. ONE IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL.
AND APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS THANK
YOU SIR [inaudible]
PLEASE.
I WRECKED TO PODIATRY COUNTY
CALIFORNIA --
WE A POPULATION OF ABOUT
THIRTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE AT
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED SQUARE MILES
AT SEVEN HUNDRED MILES RHODEN
COUNTY.
OF COURSE FOR UP NORTH FOR
MOUNTAINOUS AND WE GOT ROSE AGO
FROM ANYWHERE FROM THOUSAND
FEET.
TO SIX A THOUSAND FEET ABOUT 60%
OF OUR ROAD MILES CONNECT
COMMUNITIES THEY'RE NOT REALLY
IN THE RESIDENTIAL AREAS IN A
COURSE.
LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE WE HAVE
FIRES FLOODS MUD SLIDE IN.
QUITE FRANKLY BILLS SELF
COUNTIES MOVE IN EVERY WEEK.
SO.
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE --
LAST WINNER A TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
WITH FORTY TWO SITES WITH
SEVENTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS DAMAGE --
FOR WHAT WE NEED IN OUR COUNTY
TO RUN THE DOT WE NEED A
NINETEEN PEOPLE TO PLOW THE
ROADS IN A BIG SNOWSTORM.
AND WE NEED --
FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO KEEP OUR PCI --
FIFTY EIGHT WHAT WE HAD TWO
THOUSAND LEVEL WAS WE HAD FIVE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS BUT
SINCE THEN WE'VE LOST SECURE
RULE SCHOOLS.
AND THE HUDA TO WEAR AND SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN WE'RE DOWN TO TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWELVE EMPLOYEES WHAT WHAT DID
TWELVE EMPLOYEES BECAUSE OF
PROBLEMS WITH WELL.
FOR ONE WE HAD A LADY WHO BROKE
BACK TWENTY MILES OFF STATE
HIGHWAY UP COUNTY ROAD.
AND IT TOOK US TWELVE HOURS TO
GET UP TO GET HER RESCUER DURING
A SNOWSTORM.
A MATTER OF FACT YOU GO --
TO TWENTY COUNTYSNOW PLOWMAN
SNOWSTORMS ON THE C. ACT PERCY
SEX SITE WE HAVE A VIDEO BALUN.
AND ALSO WE HAD A FAMILY THEY
GOT TRAPPED FOR TWO DAYS ON THE
ROAD BECAUSE CENTURY WITH TWELVE
PEOPLE WE WERE NOT ABLE TO GET
OUT THERE AND PLAY ALL THE ROADS
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
ESPECIALLY WHEN AROUND BIG
STORMS --
AND THEN FINALLY WE HAD THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY --
TO MAINTAIN THE ROADS AND THAT
MAKES A DISASTERS OF SEVENTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS --
UNATTAINABLE.
I'M AND THEN.
IN OUR COUNTY TAKES A TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS CRACK STILL
ROAD SEVEN THOUSAND CHIPS STILL
A MILE OF ROAD AND SIX THOUSAND
TO PAVE SO.
WITH THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND YOU
JUST.
CAN ONLY DO HALF MILE FEAR
SERMON AFTER ASKING AROUND OKAY
--
ANYWAYS SO WHEN S. B. ONE CAME
AROUND WE WENT UP TO FIVE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF THEY WILL
HIRE TWENTY THREE NEW PEOPLE.
OR HAVE A STAFF OF TWENTY THREE
AND THEN TEN YEARS WILL BE AT
SIX MILLION.
ESSENTIALLY I'VE BEEN THERE I'VE
DONE THAT I REALLY DON'T WANT TO
DO IT AGAIN SERMON ASK YOU TO
WRAP IT UP A THANK YOU.
PRECISION IN HE REPRESENT.
GOOD EVENING ONLY A SILVERTHORNE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
CALVET CORNEA CAMERA OF COMMERCE
OPPOSES.
REPEAL OF S. B. ONE RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE IS
VITAL TO BUSINESSES MOVING GOODS
IN THEIR EMPLOYEES GETTING TO
WORK.
THIS MEASURE WOULD ELIMINATE
REVENUES ALREADY FLOWING TO
EVERY CITY AND COUNTY TO FIX
POTHOLES MAKE SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS IN EASE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION.
WOULD DIRECTLY HURT JOB
CREATION.
SEE EIGHT THOUSAND GOOD PAYING
JOBS AND A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
ECONOMIC GROWTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT SEEMS
LIKE I MAY BE THE LAST PERSON SO
WITH THAT --
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION BEING THE FIRST
PEOPLE TO OPPOSE.
I'M JUST A CITIZEN SO I'M NOT
HERE REPRESENTING ANYBODY MY
NAME IS JOHN MCKENZIE NAM.
OBVIOUSLY ROAD IMPROVEMENTS ARE
NECESSARY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS A LEGAL ANALYST
OFFICE MENTIONED NO PREVIOUS GAS
TAX MONEY HAS GONE TO THIS.
SO -- HOW
THE STATE PEN CITIZENS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA REALLY
TRUST?
THAT --
FURTHER FUNDS ARE GONNA GO
EXACTLY WHERE IT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE.
SO THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
ONE TO BE ADDRESSED ADDRESSED
DIRECTLY AND THAT GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS WHO CHOOSE TO MAKE
DECISIONS WITHOUT THE
CONSIDERATIONS OF THE CITIZENS
--
THE FROM THIS POINT FORWARD IT
LOOKS LIKE WE'LL BE HAND WILL BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
AND THE INFANT TOYS NATION ARE
FROM GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
DIRECTLY THE CITIZENSHIP.
IS LIKELY TO FACE OPPOSITION SO
AS THE ONLY CITIZEN HERE THAT'S
ACTUALLY SPEAKING DIRECTLY FOR
THEMSELVES --
THAT'S MY PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE NO SPEAKER.
BILL HIGGINS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS REPRESENTING OUR
MEMBERS TOGETHER REPRESENT ABOUT
98% OF THE STTE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HELP PROGRAM AND FUND
MANY THE TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
AROUND THE STATE.
WE WITHOUT WITH THE SP ONE IS
MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN EVERY
REGION IN THE STATE THERE ARE
MORE LOCAL SAFETY PROJECTS MORE
POTHOLES BEING FILLED AND
HELPING PEOPLE GET TO WORK ON
TIME AND GET HOME TO SPEND WITH
THEIR FAMILIES ON TIME.
AND IT'S THIS PART OF QUALITY OF
LIFE IMPROVEMENT THAT'S HELPING
EVERY CALIFORNIA WHICH MAKE
EVERY CALIFORNIAN WHICH MAKES S.
B..
ONE APPRECIATED BY EVERY
COMMUNITY IN THE STATE THANK
YOU.
THE OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT LIKE TO SPEAK WITH FOR A
WIN.
ONE WHICH NAME THE REPRESENT
PLACE.
GOOD EVENING CARL TAMAYO WITH
REFORM CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE
PROPONENTS.
ON THE GAS TAX REPEAL
INITIATIVE.
I WE WERE A LITTLE STUNNED THAT
THE COMMITTEE CHOSE NOT TO HEAR.
FROM THE PROPONENTS [inaudible]
SHOWS -- TO
NOT EVEN AN INFORMATIVE YOU'RE
HEARING.
BUT I GUESS IT'S PAR FOR THE
COURSE AND HOW THIS CAMPAIGN.
IS LIKELY TO EVOLVE.
HOW THIS MEASURE CAME ABOUT
[inaudible]
BACKROOM DEALS.
WITHOUT PUBLIC SCRUTINY WITHOUT
[inaudible]
REAL FAX.
I AM ADMIRE THOSE [inaudible]
HERE TODAY CLAIM. TO WANT TO
REBUILD OUR ROADS.
OUR ROADS NEED TO BE REBUILT.
HOWEVER WE ALREADY PAY
[inaudible]
THE PRIVILEGE.
OF GOOD ROADS.
THE SECOND HIGHEST GAS TAX IN
THE COUNTRY BEFORE THIS INCREASE
WENT INTO EFFECT.
SO I ASK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND WE ALREADY KNOW THE ANSWER
WHAT YOU DO WITH THE MONEY.
WHY DIDN'T WE REBUILD THE ROADS?
WHY DON'T WE FILL THE POTHOLES?
BECAUSE WE'RE TOO BUSY FILLING
THE PENSION HOLE.
BECAUSE WE WERE TOO BUSY ADDING
STAFF.
WITHOUT ACTUALLY WORRYING ABOUT
COMPLETING PROJECTS.
BECAUSE WE WERE TOO BUSY
ELIMINATING LANES WITHROW DIETS
[inaudible]
TRANSFERRING MONEY TO COVER THE
GENERAL FUND BUDGET DEFICIT.
AND OF COURSE DECIDING THAT
ROADS ARE IMPORTANT.
BUT MASS TRANSIT INNER CITY
LIGHT RAIL HIGH SPEED RAIL IS
MORE IMPORTANT.
WE NEED TO REJECT THE TAX
INCREASE.
YOU SHOULD HAVE DONE THIS BY
NOW.
ONE OF YOUR MEMBERS LOST HIS
JOB.
BECAUSE OF THIS AND I WILL
SUBMIT TO YOU THAT MORE OF YOU
WILL PROBABLY LOSE YOUR JOBS.
IN THE NOVEMBER ELECTION BECAUSE
THIS IS ON THE BALLOT.
AND RIGHTFULLY SO.
YOU FORCED THE TAXPAYERS. TO
COLLECT ALMOST A MILLION
SIGNATURES.
BECAUSE YOU WILL NOT LISTEN TO
THEM.
BUT YOU WILL HEAR THEM IN
NOVEMBER.
DO MATTER WHAT HAS SPENT
CERTAINLY ASK YOU BUT UP TWO
MINUTES NO MATTER WHAT YOU SPEND
NO MATTER WHAT SORT OF
MISINFORMATION YOU PROVIDE.
THE VOTERS WILL REJECT THIS AND
THEN WE GOT TO SIT DOWN AND
REBUILD OUR ROADS.
WITH THE MONEY THAT WE ARE IF
PROVIDED FIXER [inaudible]
PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBER SLEEPING IF WINTERS HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED
GENERAL CONTRACTORS A CALIFORNIA
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND REALLY FOR ALL OF
YOUR EXTREME WORK HERE. TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU PUT BEFORE THE
VOTERS THE ABSOLUTE PROTECTIONS
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE PROTECT THESE MONIES IN
PROPOSITION SIXTY NINE ACA.
FIVE BUT REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE
ABLE TO PROTECT THE INVESTMENT
THAT ALL OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS
THE RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
ABSOLUTELY TO SERVE.
WE KNOW AS A MATTER OF FACT THAT
WE HAVE LOST PURCHASING POWER
AND ANY TIME YOU DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THE WAY THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LOCAL
COMMUNITIES OF HAD TO DO.
OVERTIME GETS FOR MORE EXPENSIVE
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO FIX THE
ROADS AND SO THIS A MEASURE
SENATE BILL ONE WAS A GREAT
MOMENT FOR US IN CALIFORNIA IT
REINSTATED OR ABILITY TO ADDRESS
THE CONDITION OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT WAS FORTIFIED WITH
PROTECTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
FRAZIER FOR PUTTING THEM MEASURE
BEFORE THE VOTERS AND IT'S A
REAL OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO MOVE
THE NEEDLE AND FIX THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SO
DESERVEDLY NEEDS ATTENTION SO
FOR THAT.
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR
HELP.
ANY OF THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT LIKE TO SPEAK [inaudible]
THIS HEARING.
PRO OR CON [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WILL MOVE ON TO US THERE'S BEST
MAPS TO MEMBERS AND IT DIDN'T
HEAR THEIR LA ONLY MAY HAVE A A
QUESTION OR TWO OF THE LA THOSE
AND I'M GONNA GIVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IF
WE AREN'T [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
SERENA [inaudible]
SEEING.
THANK YOU FOR SHOWING UP TODAY
--
MISTER ELLIOTT PAUL.
WE KEEP IT YOU ME AND BEST
FRIENDS --
SO SO WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAID OF A
JOINT JUST THIS AFTERNOON.
WHO WANT TO THANK THE PUBLIC FOR
THEIR COMMENTS AND BRING THIS
OUT WE DID ADVERTISE THIS?
OFFER FOR CONTINUAL DAYS --
GOING FORWARD AS WE ARE
REQUIRED.
TO AND OF ALL IS HOW MY VICE
CHAIR I HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
AND COME WILL MOVE ON THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE COMING AND AND AND NOW.
EXPRESSING THEIR OPINIONS UP.
I CAN I THINK I CAN SPEAK FOR
EVERYONE ON THIS DIES THAT NO
ONE OPPOSES INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT --
THERE ARE CLEAR DISAGREEMENTS ON
HOW TO FUND INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS AND I THINK IT'S
VERY APPARENT.
A OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS THAT
CALIFORNIA MOTORISTS AND COWBOY
RESIDENTS THEY WANT TO SAY AND
SO.
ON IF THIS INITIATIVE PASSES I
THINK IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY
AS LEGISLATORS TO TALK ABOUT
ALTERNATIVES TO FIGURE OUT.
FUNDING MECHANISMS THAT COULD
YOU COULD YOU BE USE CONTINUE TO
FUNDING OF IMPORTANT
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
A WE JUST PASSED A EL HUNDRED
NINE NINE BILLION DOLLAR --
BUDGET WITH LESS THAN.
THREE IN THAT BUDGET THAT WILL
GO TO ROAD [inaudible]
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND SO IF OUR PRIORITIES AND IF
EVERYONE AGREES.
THAT TRANSPORTATION ROAD
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A PRIORITY.
THEN WE MUST MATCH THAT PRIORITY
WITH FUNDING.
AND SO IF LESS THAN 3% OF OUR
FUNDING IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
IS GOING TO ROADS THEY'RE WE
NEED TO ANSWER TO THE PUBLIC FOR
THAT.
AND SO THERE IS PROPOSITION TWO
THE RAINY DAY FUND.
IN THAT SENSE CLEARLY STATES
THAT IF WE WANT TO SAVE ABOVE
AND BEYOND THE RAINY DAY FUND
THAT THAT FUNDING.
WOULD GO TEMPERATURE AFTER THE
FOLLOWING BUDGET YEAR.
AND THIS LEGISLATURE CHOSE NOT
TO PUT ANY MORE FUNDING INTO THE
MADE A FINE UNDER PROP.
TWO AND SO WE HAD THAT CHOICE
AND WE DIDN'T MAKE THAT CHOICE
AND SO.
WE NEED TO BE RESPONSIBLE AND I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIRMEN IN HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IS THAT WE
NEED TO FUND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
I THINK THAT WE PROBABLY NEED TO
GO ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN INVESTED.
ARE CURRENTLY I THINK MOST OF
THE PROPONENTS ABOUT SIZA
OPPONENTS AND PROPONENTS OF AS
WE WANT I WOULD AGREE THAT WE
NEED PUBLIC SHOULD BE SPENDING
MORE ON INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND SEES THE SAFETY AND AND A
WHOLE HOST OF THINGS THAT WOULD
NOT ONLY INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY
BUT ALSO.
A TO PROVIDE NEEDED INVESTMENTS
TO REDUCE TRAFFIC CONGESTION SO
I WOULD JUST ASK THAT AS WE
DISCUSS LEARN THE FUTURE OF
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AND TRANSMISSION INVESTMENT IS
THAT THIS DISCUSSION DOESN'T END
HERE.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY.
THE PUBLIC WANTS A VOICE SO NOW
WE AT THE WE ANSWERED TO THE
PUBLIC.
THE VOTERS ARE OUR BOSSES.
AND SO WE DID IS WE DESERVEDLY
NEED TO GIVE THE VOTERS A CHOICE
ON WHETHER S. B. ONE IS TO CRACK
POLICY NOT SO I THINK YOU
APPRECIATE THE JENNIFER LET ME
SPEAK.
WHO I AM?
ONE OTHER SPEAKER FROM THE THE
DICE MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PERSONALITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS HEARING IN.
FALL THE TESTIMONY HAS BEEN
GIVEN THOSE FAR --
I JUST WANT TO MAKE MENTION THAT
I HAVE HEARD FROM VOTERS I'M AT
LEAST IN MY DISTRICT --
AND I'VE HEARD IT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN BOTH AS A CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER WHO HAD TO BE --
MAKE DECISIONS --
TERMS OF OUR BUDGET.
AND REALIZE THAT WE CANNOT
AFFORD TO PAY FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE --
THAT -- WE
NEED TO PAY FOR WITH IN OUR OWN
CITY BUDGET.
AND WOOD SP ONE CAME ALONG.
IT WAS CERTAINLY THE RIGHT THING
TO DO.
THE VOTERS IN MY DISTRICT
[inaudible]
PORTED.
WE ARE SEEING THE MANIFESTATION
OF S. B. ONE TAKING PLACE.
BY INFRASTRUCTURE NO ROADS
BEING.
TAKING CARE BEING A REPAIRED --
PEOPLE ARE SAYING I CAN NOW
DRIVE DOWN CENTRAL AVENUE.
AND OTHER PARTS OF THE DISTRICT
AS WELL AND SO I THINK THAT WE
HAVE IN FACT HEARD.
OF VOTERS --
CINNAMINSON CONCERNS --
BY DOING THIS I MISSED SOMETHING
THAT I THINK THAT IS VERY WELL
SUPPORTED.
IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT THINK
MAKE GOOD SENSE OF THE
TESTIMONIES THAT I'VE HEARD THUS
FAR TODAY FROM THE DIFFERENT
CITIES WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF SB
ONE GOES AWAY.
IT WOULD BE DEVASTATING --
TO THE FOUR HUNDRED PLUS CITIES
I'M WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO I THINK THIS
IS A VERY PRUDENT I THINK THIS
IS BACK ZACH LEE WHAT.
OF THE VOTERS OF OF CALIFORNIANS
LISA MY DISTRICT I'M SUPPORT --
AND ONE AND I THINK IT'S BEEN
ECHOED THOSE WHO REPRESENT THEM
THEM THE DIFFERENT CITIES WHO
HAVE COME HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS
ON BEHALF OF THOSE PARTICULAR
CITIES I THINK YOU.
AND I THINK THAT AGAIN IT WOULD
BE DEVASTATING FOR THE FACT OF
THIS IS REPEAL AND SO I FOR ONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR BOTH CHAIRS FOR
ALLOWING US.
TO HAVE THIS AUDIENCE TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR BILLION MAKING
COMMENTS ON THE POST.
WE JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
PUBLIC UNION FOR A RESPONDING --
I TOWARDS SP ONE IS IN THE
POSITIVE.
IT TOOK US TWO YEARS FOUR MONTHS
AND SIX DAYS AFTER THE GOVERNOR
DID HIS STATE OF THE STATE --
DECLARING THE THE DESPERATE
NEED.
FOR OF TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
AND TRAVELING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TALKING TO STAKEHOLDERS.
ABOUT WHAT WOULD BE A GOOD
COMPROMISE A GOOD HOPEFULLY
PACKAGE --
THAT WOULD ADDRESS ALL THE NEEDS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
OTHER IS A PERFECT NO.
BUT THERE'S A TENS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS BACKLOG IN REPAIRS
THAT WE'RE NOT ACKNOWLEDGING AND
THAT WHEN I SERVE ON THE CDC AS
AN EX OFFICIO SENATOR BELL.
AND I SAW THE THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION DE
PROGRAM PROJECTS.
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T ENOUGH
RESOURCES REVENUE.
THAT WAS ABSOLUTELY THE WRONG
DIRECTION TO GO.
THIS IS AN ABILITY TO MOVE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD AND COMMERCE
IN SAFETY.
AND AND INVESTMENT IN INDUSTRY
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS.
THAT NEED TO BE TAKEN CARE OF
AND AGAIN AS THE AUTHOR OF A CA
FIVER PROP.
SIXTEEN NINE THE LOCK BOX WHICH
WILL MAKE SURE THE DOLLARS ARE
CONTINUALLY USE FOR
TRANSPORTATION.
OTHER TO STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO GIVE THE PUBLIC
ASSURANCE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN USE IT FOR ANY OTHER
PURPOSE.
SO WITH THAT WILL ADJOURN THIS
HEARING.
I LOOK FORWARD TO A POSITIVE
RESULT -- IN
THE EFFORTS TO CONTINUE TO
PROMOTE INFASTRUCTURE AND SAFETY
IN CALIFORNIA.
AYE YOU WILL MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT REVENUE TAX
WILL -- BE
IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX ARE GOING
FORWARD.
OF MEMBERS OF THIS
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WE'RE
GONNA.
TAKE A COUPLE MINUTES TO RESET
AND HAVE OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
ON A ONE BILL.
SO THANK YOU OF MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WE'RE GONNA JOIN THIS
PUBLIC HEARING THANK YOU.